hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Monday morning podcast
for Monday December 31st 2018 case you
thought there was thirty two days in
December this is the last day of 2018
what are you gonna do with it are you
gonna seize the day seize the day
aka cram too much [ __ ] into a 24-hour
period so you're [ __ ] stressed out
for the next day that's how I do it
that's how I do it
oh by the way guess what I finally got
that little [ __ ] piece I needed for
my for my headphones and it works great
and as you see i sat there and i [ __ ]
bitched about it for what six [ __ ]
felt like nine years i just ordered it
on amazon it showed up you know some
[ __ ] eight-year-old put on a welding
mast and made it there than somebody
else flew it on a [ __ ] what do you
call those goddamn things that hover
over your neighborhood drone yeah I
don't know anyways happy New Year to you
happy New Year to you you're gonna get
shit-faced call an uber or a lift I'm
actually gonna be going out tonight for
the first time in a long time I'm gonna
be going I'm just going out with my my
old family my family baggage we're just
gonna go out to dinner it's cool being a
dad you know what I mean right then I'm
going to go booze and all that [ __ ] you
just [ __ ] call two days before do you
have a reservation at 4:00 in the
afternoon
4:30 like why yes yes we do it's like
any other day here at 4:00 or 4:30 in
the afternoon however you know starting
around 7:00 no we don't completely
booked and everything's going to be
jacked up the a/o so we're all gonna go
out and have a hopefully a pleasurable
meal enjoyable dinner and all that type
of stuff and then I go to the Rose Bowl
the next day and then the following day
gimme a ticket on an aeroplane gonna go
fly to [ __ ] Eastern Europe
I'm gonna go to Cologne Germany and then
I'd starts and I am ready baby I put it
at time they did the [ __ ] war I was
down in the Comedy Store every night the
last three nights and the Icehouse you
know I [ __ ] up Thursday night I
[ __ ] I [ __ ] up twice on my gigs
this week which I never do I actually
was headlining the Ice House and I
forgot and I put it at The Comedy Store
so I'm pulling into the Comedy Store at
like 9 o'clock and I just happen to look
down on my phone I see a Joe Rogan phone
call and he was the one who told me to
you know that they wanted to book me at
the ice house then I was like oh [ __ ]
and then I saw I had a bunch of missed
messages from the club owner and I
called up I was like what time was I
supposed to be onstage he's like right
now 10 minutes ago so I drove out there
like a maniac I finally learned how to
use the supercharger in my car you know
so I was in intense mode whatever the
[ __ ] they call it like I drove that car
for [ __ ] two years never using the
supercharger because I didn't know you
had to push a button I just thought when
I stepped on the gas like the old days
it would just engage over there but it
didn't so I finally learned how to use
that thing and what is going on with
these [ __ ] wires why can't I get them
ever not to eat just I don't understand
you know it's weird you could take a
handful of wires and throw them on the
ground and then once you pick one of
them up they all tie together you know
it's so weird that you can do that with
like wires but you can't do it with
snakes if you throw them on the [ __ ]
ground and you just pick one of them up
there wouldn't be a bunch of them all
tangled up in it they all just [ __ ]
slither away so what I'm saying is we
need to start making wires the way the
good Lord makes the snakes anyway so
then I had to drive all the way back to
the Comedy Store because I was so
[ __ ] late at the Ice House I hung out
took pictures and sign [ __ ]
you know to make up for that did the
full hour then I went all the way back
to the [ __ ] comedy store I got there
but like a quarter to 12:00 at night and
I got to tell you I haven't gone up you
know I never went up really
at The Comedy Store because I never got
past their to go through that and I went
back to me you know I auditioned for
Mitzi and she said I and she saying she
left in the middle of my session that's
how [ __ ] awful she thought I was and
she's probably right if I'm gonna be
mature about it and then I just I moved
back to New York and I sort of did the
late-night thing in New York and I never
got to do at the Comedy Store and that's
probably the latest I've gone on there
since I can remember and it was just a
completely different animal I went on in
the main room and then also in the
original room and in the main room I was
on stage and I was thinking about
Richard Pryor for some reason because I
know that there's some good older guys
they had told me how he used to work out
his stuff late night there and then when
I went into the o.r I was you know I
just went up there and I had like this
[ __ ] set where I was just totally
free riffin said all this [ __ ] didn't
tape any of it just [ __ ] that I would a
few things I remembered that now in my
act but like and I remembered hearing
this story that Jim Carrey came up with
fire marshal bill late night in the o.r
at the Comedy Store and all that [ __ ]
was really ended up being really cool
and then I worked two shows Friday there
to show Saturday and then last night I
was running my hour in the main room and
then I was running over to the whisky
because Steven Adler was playing and I
also had another spot in the o.r but
instead of just doing an hour I did like
an hour and 40 in the main room and I
was gonna be late for the Steven Adler
show so I was like is it cool if I just
don't do that spot cuz I didn't know
that they advertised me in that room - I
thought they just advertised me in the
main room but they had also advertised
me in the or had I known that I would
have gone over there and done it I just
thought I had a spot and I missed it
because I was supposed to go up at 10:15
and by the time I got off stage in the
main room was like 10:40 I was like I
don't want to [ __ ] it up over there you
know for the other people
so anyways long story short I saw Steven
Adler [ __ ] great show at The Whisky
and then I'm walking back to the store
and I'm walking in front of the store
and these four people are standing at
like [ __ ] two of them 1:30 in the
morning going he gotta be [ __ ] me
you gonna go on now I go be talking
about it was on in the main rooms they
could know you we were in the Oh are we
were sitting there for five hours the
whole crowd
[ __ ] pissed off so I I don't know I
got to try to figure out how to [ __ ]
make that right but I felt like a
[ __ ] [ __ ] so I took a picture with
them and I don't know I know I was
thinking why the [ __ ] did I do that
because then I went over to the Adler
thing and it started like you know 20
minutes later I would have had time to
do it
then I wouldn't disappointed those
people and I feel like a [ __ ] [ __ ]
but having said that you know I I
basically did like seven sets and missed
one so what are you gonna do
but dude the [ __ ] Adler apatite show
that thing was [ __ ] great man and I
was just sitting there the whole show I
was just watching Stephen because I
started listening you know I don't know
I I kind of tuned up my drums and I got
some different heads and [ __ ] and they
sound [ __ ] killer and then my drum
teacher came over and he fine-tuned it
and now it just sounds [ __ ]
unbelievable and I was listening to just
that apatite album again and I'm such a
drum nerd do you realize that Steven
Adler does not hit his rack tom until
like like the fourth song like halfway
through the fourth song he crushes that
album just with the bass drum snare in
his floor Tom the only time he really
hits the floor tom is the breakdown
during welcome to the jungle out to get
me is all just kick snare now I'm sorry
what's the next I would say think it's
out to get me it's a it's so easy is all
kick snare and what's the next one dah
dah dah dah
no that's on the other side I don't
[ __ ] know but anyway so I was
watching him and then when I watched him
last night
the Phil that I thought he was doing in
one of those [ __ ] songs he actually
didn't do on the rack he actually went
from the snare over to the floor so I
actually think he goes maybe to mr.
brownstone
nobody even then that's a floor tom but
I've ever seen this whole [ __ ] thing
is born a lot of you guys but uh I spent
but seeing this whole [ __ ] thing on
on that for a while he only had a
three-piece and it's just amazing how
his so style came out of being a broke
musician and just crashing at people's
places he couldn't have a big drum kit
if he wanted to he started out for the
double bass kit I remember reading in
his book and then they got rid of that
he got rid of that somehow somebody said
don't play double bass just play a
single bass drum assumption it almost
like a bottom thing and then he was down
to like just a floor kick and snare and
just the amount of music that that guy
got out of it but uh it was awesome it
was just do what a bunch of characters
at the whiskey last night Jesus Christ
there was this [ __ ] guy there right
and I just he looked and he looked like
he was like in his 50s but he literally
he had a hard life so he's probably like
in his 40s and he's just standing all of
a sudden the bouncer comes up and he
just hits him like slaps him on the arm
like what the [ __ ] and then the guy kind
of gestures like hey man you know I mean
suck it's cool whatever
and the bouncer just grabs him and
[ __ ] throws him out of the club so my
buddy I was with went up and said hey
man just out of curiosity what did that
guy do and I guess the guy had taken out
his lighter and was [ __ ] light in the
ass of the person in front of him like
some other dude so when the bouncer hit
him like what the [ __ ] you doing he was
making this gesture yeah that's kind of
funny right in the pumps get the [ __ ]
out of here you [ __ ] lighting people
on 40 what do you give him somebody lit
a hot foot it's 50 years of [ __ ] age
and my other buddy was with was laughing
his ass off I'm so loud I mean I didn't
could have just gone to him but he was
sitting there going like was laughing
going yeah I saw the whole [ __ ] thing
like you didn't even try to hide it it's
a complete [ __ ] [ __ ] so anyways
that's why I did it my apology so people
that came down to the o.r last night I
feel I really feel [ __ ] badly about
that man I I mean it's a hand I don't
know how many times in my life I've
missed a spot I would I think it's
under 10 my entire [ __ ] career the
first nine times nobody gave a [ __ ] so
my apologies I hope that somehow I can
make that up to you guys anyways plowing
ahead here speaking of shows we've added
two more amazing comics
these guys are kids to me but they're
not they're [ __ ] that they're like
legit I'm just old as [ __ ] Joe list and
Mark Norman have been added to the
lineup for the 7th annual Patrice O'Neal
comedy benefit I had the privilege of
working with both of them mark Normand I
worked at the Westside comedy club in
New York City and Joe lists when I did
Gotham about a month ago I got to work
with both of them and just it's just
[ __ ] like that they're like the next
guys just legit legit straight up
[ __ ] comedians and we'll be monster
headliners so come down and see them now
while you still can
also on the show as I've been mentioning
Michelle wolf Chris read Jim Gaffigan
Gary Gulman rich vos Cypress sounds big
Jay oakerson and myself it's going to be
a monster monster monster show and
thanks to the Joe Rogan experience we
had 800 tickets to sell and now we're
down to like 150 so people can buy
tickets at WWE York City oh sorry NY
City Center org or on my website which
is Bill burr commie if you just click on
the events or whatever the hell it is
Road gigs or some [ __ ] like that if you
just click on that [ __ ] you'll see the
link right there
alright so there you go speak in a Rogen
you know I mentioned when I did his
podcast how I took a sauna with the MAF
tours and he has like a legit sauna you
know the ones would like the coals and
[ __ ] that you dump the water on so I
felt so great after that said I was kind
of jonesing for another one so I went to
this [ __ ] place out here I'm not
gonna say the name because I'm kind of
gonna like not [ __ ] on the place but
it's just more like it's a different
kind of different kind of sauna
where Jo's is the old-school one that
that like you know the heat hits you
from the outside and you sweat like that
I went to one of those infrared ones the
clear light [ __ ] ones which I
realized is this whole debate on whether
or not those things are healthy or not
and they say yeah you know we checked
out the [ __ ] and raised on this thing
it's fine and then you're supposed to
ask them well how did you measure those
rays is there any radiation because they
were like this thing like heats you from
the inside is the way they described and
I go really I go I feel like I'm getting
into a microwave and I got to tell you I
stayed in there for a [ __ ] hour and
when I came out I definitely felt better
but afterwards I didn't feel right it
just didn't feel right it wasn't that
same peaceful feeling that I had coming
out of the other one so I didn't like
the infrared ones although I heard this
some Hollywood starlets that just swear
by him I guess they use it for weight
loss and I will tell you I came out of
there and my stomach was definitely
flattered but I'm like isn't that all
water weight you know you go out and
have one sarsaparilla there you [ __ ]
belly comes right back isn't that how it
works
but anyway some gonna go do this this
Europe tour and I'm hoping they hit a
couple of those places when I'm over
there this is gonna be an unprecedented
road trip for me in that I won't be
drinking I don't even know that I want
to smoke cigars because I have like
[ __ ] 90 over the past week you know
catching up with everybody end of the
year hey let's get a [ __ ] to go so I
won't be smoking cigars
I got vitamins with me and I'm gonna try
to be hitting the saunas and [ __ ]
getting eight hours sleep just cuz it my
[ __ ] age man I can't be doing like
city to city to city to city ten days
two shows almost every [ __ ] night you
know oh my god I was gonna say that the
tour I'm gonna have a [ __ ] cane I saw
a guy last night you know those people
that have [ __ ] canes and it's just
like dude you don't need a [ __ ] cane
this guy was like walking with this cane
and he would take like three steps
before he put the cane down you know it
was like watching a point guard
dribbling the
all up the court where you just watching
the whole time going like the guy's
[ __ ] traveling if you don't set it on
an NBA game like you [ __ ] watch these
guys the bouncing the ball like so
[ __ ] high and you watch him 1 2 3
bounce 1 2 3 bounce 1 2 3 bounce one to
bounce 1 2 3 it's just like actually
supposed to I mean that wasn't like a
step and a half I don't know how it
[ __ ] works I'm done bitching about
sports in the way it is nowadays I
finally given in to the fact that his
changed and speaking of which my
Patriots beat the New York Jets so I was
impressed with their quarterback I don't
know if he's gonna be the guy but yeah
you know you never know
might be coaching might be his line I
have no idea but he made some good
throws and there was a lot of [ __ ]
heavy hits by their defense you know
they haven't another rough year or
whatever but we handled them we got a
playoff spot we got a bye for the ninth
time 9 years in a row we got a bye but
that [ __ ] [ __ ] stupid ass
[ __ ] Dolphins game now now we're
gonna have to go through Casey if we win
our game and they win their game we're
gonna have to go through Kansas City we
have to try to beat those [ __ ] guys
again in their own goddamn building and
I don't know I don't I just don't see
that happening with the the I don't know
which weird this year we have actually
have a really good running game it seems
but it's hard to gauge cuz you're
playing the Jets and they were all
banged up on defense so I don't I don't
really know where the [ __ ] we stand here
but uh but who knows Kansas City you
know they also have to win which is not
something that they've done in the
postseason for a long [ __ ] time but
uh that mahomes guys on a whole other
level and I don't know that you know
Paul virzi made up a great [ __ ] point
just saying that you know that I don't I
think this is the first time Andy Reid
has ever had a quarterback I know he had
done 'van McNabb and all on that [ __ ]
but I really think this mahomes guy he
has that he seems to have that you
almost have to be like not human at the
end of the game where you just don't
feel emotion you know
Mersey basically said all right I don't
like cuz I like dumb that if he goes
this is the first time you know he had
he's got a guy like bombs he didn't have
a guy you know you know he was in
Philadelphia and had a guy who puked in
the [ __ ] huddle or whatever which I
don't that's probably overblown knows he
probably went out partied the night
before
I'm sure [ __ ] can't stay but puked in
a couple of [ __ ] Huddle's anyways and
congratulations to the Cleveland Browns
I'm just a great season and I was really
pulling for you guys yesterday just to
see you have a winning season and all
that [ __ ] I don't know we'll see this is
gonna be a great postseason of course
I'm gonna be over season miss some of it
and if my Patriots aren't gonna win it
all I almost want us to lose in the
first round just so I can sit there and
[ __ ] enjoy it
I know I'm going to enjoy the NFC
playoffs just as far as like you know
the Saints have home-field I still don't
think Drew Brees has ever gotten the
[ __ ] respect he deserves
he's one of those guys where he's gonna
have to win to the people for people
being oh yeah but then again Eli's one
too and they're treating him like a
[ __ ] stepchild I don't know when the
Rams would just killing the host season
and then they kind of had that little
dip there and now they kind of back but
they also played the 49ers so I don't
know I don't know and then you got
Seattle and they got Pete Carroll is a
great [ __ ] coach anything can happen
and then Chicago has that great D this
is gonna be [ __ ] fun it's gonna be fun
I was always kind of wondering - like
what Brady must feel like being this far
into his goddamn career where he must
feel like a [ __ ] a townie at the bar
and everybody else has kind of gotten on
with their lives just looking around the
locker room like where the [ __ ] is
everybody that I used to know they're
all [ __ ] gone and in like there's no
quarterback left in the league that was
playing when he started out I
I almost think like I mean he makes
[ __ ] Eli and drew brees look like
youngsters kind of the way the Rolling
Stones kept Aerosmith young for so long
well they were able to kind of breeze
through their 40s 50s and into their 60s
because the stones were always ten years
older than them so everyone was always
making the old jokes with them so I
don't know and for all you [ __ ] Europe
[ __ ] over there I did watch the
Liverpool Arsenal I watched until it was
three two one and then daddy duty took
over both Arsenal blows up one to
nothing and I'm thinking okay you know
that [ __ ] guy does his little dance
he slides on his knees and I'm like oh
here we go
Arsenal aye Arsenal is actually a team
that I've [ __ ] heard of they must be
they must be one of the good [ __ ]
teams and then the Liverpool guys they
just went right down the [ __ ] field
like [ __ ] three minutes later BAM 90
seconds later BAM which you've never
seen [ __ ] soccer football whatever
the hell you call it it's the same guy
when we guys hadn't scored at all in the
Premier League
just weak-ass [ __ ] defense the one
where most salic kind of [ __ ] weaved
his way through and then made that sick
past for the third goal or something
when they showed that defense in slow
motion it looks lit literally looked
like they were extras in a movie and Mo
was like the star that they had to make
look good so they were doing these
half-hearted sort of I don't know what
trying to get their foot in the way it's
like don't they usually just [ __ ]
stick a cleat right in the back of your
[ __ ] Achilles I don't know I don't
know [ __ ] about these goddamn that
goddamn sport but I have been watching
or whatever
alright let me read a little bit of
advertising here what do we got here
this o simply safe everybody don't you
want to be simply safe in 2019 isn't
that where you want to be simply safe we
all put off doing things we we know we
need to do I mean we know we need to
organise the garage or please
personalise your own ideas
if they have a literally trying to write
this in my my [ __ ] the way I speak
this is all written like this we all put
off things we know we need to do I mean
we know we need to organize the garage
but something always gets in the way
funny how home security can be like that
you know it's what I need to organize I
don't know I cleaned up my [ __ ] drum
room change the head on all my drums so
you know what I actually moved all the
drums out of there and I brought a
little vacuum cleaner in there and I all
the [ __ ] all the [ __ ] shavings and
[ __ ] and broken drumsticks and all that
from the from the drumsticks vacuumed
all of that [ __ ] up and yeah I don't
know what this has to do with safes but
that was definitely a personal story
funny how some security can be like that
you know it's a good idea but there's
always something holding you back well
now it's time to act because simply safe
home security Holliday sale ends soon
simply safe believes nothing should come
between you and protecting your home so
they've gotten rid of the reasons not to
get home security there's no contract no
price markups from any middleman and no
installation windows who has times for
that who has time for that
most of all you're not gonna do it you
can hire somebody to do what I guess
most importantly their system is
engineered to do one thing brilliantly
protect so if a storm takes out your
power simply safe is ready if an
intruder cut your phone line simply safe
is ready if they destroy your keypad or
siren simply safe will get you the help
you need
maybe it's overkill maybe it's the last
thing you want to think about this
holiday but with simply safe you're
always ready for anything just go to
simply safecom slash bar and order
Janney before January 8th to save with
their extended holiday sale that simply
safecom slash bar simply safecom slash
bar alright simply spelled SI MP Li si
Fe has the eye instead of the Y you know
like the way a hot chick spells your
name
you know what I mean they always have
like the eye instead of a why you ever
notice that like if a chick has the wire
in their name then they just [ __ ]
regular looking like you and you're not
intimidated to approach him and [ __ ]
hit on him or whatever if you're still
allowed to do that you know
are you still allowed to do that you
know after one of my shows this woman
came up to me she's like I just want to
give you a hug and I just put my hands
straight up in the air and the whole
town's like I'm a tomeato oh my god
they're the old thing that's that's how
I'm handling every [ __ ] situation
like that I'm literally putting my hands
up like a cop has a gun on me the [ __ ]
away from me until they bring back due
process and burden of proof that's I'm
telling you is a man that is the [ __ ]
way to go to stick your hands up in the
air until these [ __ ] lunatics calm
the [ __ ] down and they realized that our
judicial system is the best that the
world has to offer and to not do away
with the best [ __ ] thing about it is
the the fact that you actually get a
[ __ ] you know the chance to defend
yourself you know even the guilty get a
chance to defend themselves so that the
innocent won't go to jail there you go
stamps calm everybody stamps calm brings
all the amazing services of the US
Postal Service right to your computer
stamps.com not only saves you time it
saves you money too with stamps.com you
get discounted postage rates that can
get even what that you can get even what
that you can't even get at the post
office
[ __ ] not to mention it's a fraction of
the cost of those expensive postage
meters and there's no equipment to least
and no long-term commitments I use
stamps our Congress sent out all my
posters for this tour I'm a [ __ ]
[ __ ] I can figure it out so can you
although I'm not bringing any these
posters to Europe by the way cuz I'm
just going from city to city to city to
city I don't know how to [ __ ] do it
over there I also don't know how to
convert the [ __ ] American money to
euros to francs to [ __ ]
the blooms whatever the [ __ ] you guys
are using over there so I'm just gonna
just gonna dance and do my stupid
[ __ ] show all right stamps common
only saves you time it saves you money
too with stamps economy can you get
discounted postage rates that you can't
even get at the post office not to
mention it's a fraction of the cost of
those expensive postage meters and
there's no equipment to lease and no
long term commitments I use stamps go
irate read this [ __ ] and right now you
can you two can enjoy the stamps.com
service with a special offer that
includes a four week trial plus postage
and a digital scale so start the new
year off right go to stamps com click on
the microphone at the top of the
homepage and type in bird that stamps
comm Interborough
oh and lastly but not leastly my bookie
hey I know [ __ ] you don't wanna put a
little money in the game you [ __ ]
so-and-so alright Bowl season is here
and it's time to get in on the action
with my bookie calm don't be that guy
don't be that [ __ ] guy over there
with no rooting interest as your
relatives or friends sit around watching
the game not this year when they are
when there are record 41 bowl games to
bet on including the national
championship on January 7th it really is
the most it really is the most wonderful
time of the year make sure you're
already ready for the daily action by
signing up at my bookie today they they
pay fast when you win ownership really
cares about good customer service and
they offer the craziest props when you
bet when you bet is just as important
with who you're betting with betting on
sorry and if you want to make money
during the bull season you got to go to
my bookie evidently I trust them
according to the [ __ ] copy here but
you don't have to take my word for it
check them out yourself join now at mine
bookie join now in my bookie will offer
you a 50% deposit bonus to make sure you
have a nice bankroll for the season use
promo code burr I'm assuming when you
deposit to activate the offer just says
xxx
that's promo code burr at my bookie you
play you when you get paid they'll get
the [ __ ] out he alright
that's the reads for this week oh you
know what I did yesterday I had a buddy
of mine he's a he's a mapper at a
country club now this is some [ __ ] that
I would never do I would never think to
do I would never think to join a country
club
I don't golf although I watch this thing
on Tiger Woods Tiger Woods last night
was some sort of [ __ ] 34:30 basically
on his return to finally winning you
know his body was all broken down on all
that [ __ ] and he came back anyone and
other ratings went like through the roof
and all of that it was just [ __ ]
awesome that she was back and you know
when people love to watch greatness if
you don't love to watch greatness that
reflects more on you rather than the
person that you [ __ ] watching because
you just [ __ ] pissed off about your
own life why wouldn't you want to see
somebody go out and be the greatest of
all time and anyways so I went over
there to smoke a cigar and and I went
over there was it was a [ __ ] utopia
like I would literally join a country
club and never play golf I went over
there they had all the NFL games on they
had all his food they were pouring booze
the way I pour booze at home I call it
like a home pour they date they were
pouring him like that fortunately I
wasn't drinking because I drove over
there and that would have been a
situation I would have to left my
[ __ ] car there but everybody just
hanging out
breaking [ __ ] balls it was great and
I got to be honest with you it was nice
as a guy to know that that still existed
it was just fun you know that's like one
of those things that like feminists go
after and it's just like we're not doing
anything wrong
and then I hung out over there for like
three hours hanging out with all the
guys everybody breaking balls telling
stories watching the game trying to
[ __ ] coach what was on the TV smoking
cigars classic guys
and then I was done and then it came
home to my wife and I was psyched and
then I was around this female energy was
perfect
it was like dare I say balanced and you
know this is this whole [ __ ] weird
thing going on right now that if
everybody is not included meaning both
sexes that for some reason that means
that there's something wrong about it
you know I don't know I don't [ __ ]
get it like you know a bunch of women
going out to brunch is great for them
they get to be around that they totally
vibe with that [ __ ] energy then after
a while I imagine they you know go onto
my [ __ ] dumb guy I'm with absence
makes the heart grow fonder you know I
understand to a certain level whether it
was just like you know entities in
business and schmoozing and all that
that weren't letting you know forget
about women but other races of people
and all that you know I'm you know
obviously not down with that I think
everybody ought to be able to go
wherever the [ __ ] they want to go as
long as you're not a [ __ ] jerk-off
but I don't but I draw the line at that
thing where it's just everything has to
have men and women mixed together I
think that a lot of [ __ ] should but I
there's definitely there should just be
some [ __ ] that's just for women or just
for men and even then just for men you
know when you color you hear I I even
when I worded that I made sure that I
said just for women first before these
[ __ ] lunatics with I don't know what
they've been doing this bit right now
talking about how these private schools
work now where you have to like audition
your kids over there and they're trying
to like get this perfect balance
racially and and in gender and all of
that and it's just like it's like their
heart is in the right place but it just
feels like this giant [ __ ] like
experiment like some weird like Nazi
[ __ ] like what do you doing with the
[ __ ] with their kids just let them be
kids and that this is all
gonna work out itself they're trying to
like they're trying to curate the the
painless childhood I think that that's
what they're going for they're gonna try
to like have kids have you know a
childhood without any pain which I guess
then the theory is is that then they
would go out into the world and they
wouldn't inflict any pain on anybody but
it's just like eventually you know you
got to go on the real world and this
cliffs gonna be pain there's gonna be
disappointment there's gonna be people
stealing your [ __ ] and you're gonna have
to know how to deal with that and that's
kind of like what school is you learn
how to stand up to bullies and all that
I'm not saying the kid should go to
school and have miserable [ __ ]
experiences but like there is like a
certain element of it that you got to
let him [ __ ] handle it themselves
right the only way that you could
possibly I don't know how it would work
you would have to get rid of all the
sociopaths and all the selfish [ __ ]
people in the world first you would
literally have to and you'd have to kill
them this whole [ __ ] thing that
you're gonna stick them on a [ __ ]
Island you know the all they're gonna do
is just [ __ ] each other and make like
[ __ ] roided-up sociopaths selfish
people and then eventually one of them
is gonna know how to make a boat and
then that's gonna be it then they going
to come over and we're all gonna be over
here like you know put you right and in
take your right hand out [ __ ] singing
the Hokey Pokey when we gotta get
steamrolled you like how I put myself
not on the island you like how in that
story I was the [ __ ] hero and I
wasn't I wasn't a selfish [ __ ] like I
wouldn't be over there I don't know it
is it is weird but I already know what
I'm gonna do I'm gonna I'm gonna get my
daughter enrolled in some sort of like
you know anti-bully jujitsu [ __ ] [ __ ]
just so my daughter knows how to handle
herself and then that's it and then just
make sure you don't abuse the skillset
that you now have and if anybody comes
at ya you know you [ __ ] handle it it
gives you confidence and then you don't
have to spend your whole [ __ ]
childhood in this depressive fog of
dreading going to school and [ __ ] you
know and I think back to some of the
periods I went through and some of the
[ __ ] some other kids that I picked on
went through I [ __ ] was like I'm and
that's it's that's I'm surprised to that
like teachers didn't intervene a little
bit more not to the point that they're
doing it now to the point that they're
doing it now what they're just [ __ ]
like it's almost like reversed Hitler
where everyone is included but they're
also deciding like who is the number one
draft pick they're still you know boxing
out other people it's weird it's just a
really [ __ ] weird I don't know it's
just such a weird goddamn time alright
that's that's it with my little [ __ ]
pontificating there let's uh let's do a
little bit of the some of the reads here
for the week all right what do we got
here who's first who's first
all right good times bad times how I
learned hey Billy bass drum balls
I learned good times bad times when I
was 12 or 13 you [ __ ]
thanks to my drum teacher no that's
awesome man he taught me healed out he
taught me healed down technique and show
me that the trick to getting those fast
flutter kicks was to move your foot
halfway down the pedal your heel should
be completely off the pedal oh yeah I've
seen that you just slide up and down
this counteracts the spring tension and
helps you play faster at the expense of
power Oh at the expense of power
all right eventually by doing this
enough you will be able to play those
flutters without this without this drink
it's like training wheels if you play
heel up you should be able to make the
swivel technique work it's a valuable
trick I have to have up your sleeve and
you don't lose any punch I've included a
link on how to do it if you aren't too
sure
I also recommend playing cashmere as a
warm-up before jumping into good times
bad times he does some slower flutter
kicks that will loosen you up I hope I
hope I could help you out Happy New Year
and go [ __ ] yourself what I learned
finally because I was doing it the wrong
way the first way I did it before I took
any drum lessons when I would do it I
would do this weird thing what I would
curl my toe down push and then almost
like I was almost doing that slide move
with like my toes and I got planar
fissure itís in my foot my technique was
so bad then my drum teacher was teaching
me his technique and I didn't understand
it and then I didn't go in for a while
and I learned it I was almost doing like
a reverse slide like I was I was
bringing my foot back and that was the
slide and then pushing forward down so
the first one was like light was almost
like an unaccented beat so I was like
that uh duh duh duh duh and then another
time I was doing it the first one was
louder it was like duh duh duh duh duh
duh and it never sounded even so the way
he just taught me which is it was has
been a total GameChanger in like the
last [ __ ] three days I've been
messing with this [ __ ] is all right I
play a DW drum pedal all right so when
you're just playing a single the ball of
your first of all you sit back and you
should be able to see your ankles a
little bit I was sitting too close so my
knee was directly above my foot and that
was [ __ ] with you know my technique
and then was you know passed up to a
certain tempo it was getting in the way
so he had me moved back which he felt
really [ __ ] weird at first and now it
feels great so basically if you were
playing a single your foot you just you
know lift your leg up and boom come
right down in the DW but when you play
hang on a sec and she's come in Indiana
all right the lovely knee is here let me
I've got to finish explaining something
here you know your shirt oddly matches
the the windscreen there yeah so anyway
it's the windscreen that I use when I'm
inside so anyways so if you play in a
single you just lift your foot up at hot
air you're blowing that's right you
bring it right down on the DW but then
if you're gonna play a double all you do
is you slide your foot back with your
right below the nine I played the 9000
so if you play the 5000 right below the
five and then you just bring your foot
down like you're playing a single so
that first one is strong okay like a
single and then as as you know and you
let the beater come off the head and you
catch the rebound as you slide it up and
then they're both strong and both even
and it sound powerful it was just a
completely different thing and what I
ended up doing at a slow tempo was just
play like in my time of dying not
playing 16th on the hi-hat I was just
playing dumb like boom bump of debt but
bump up on debt the gun took the debt
but boom boom boom put that bone
something like that whatever so it makes
sense to drummers okay it makes sense to
drummers so what's is key in that it was
what everything played like the
immigrant song is if you're playing
singles and doubles you get that muscle
memory that if you're playing a single
you just keep your foot up at the top of
the pedal and then when you play the
double you're bringing it back and what
happens is your muscle memory is as
you're playing whatever the [ __ ] you're
playing right before that first note of
the double your foots already moving
back into position be the same thing if
you're playing a double pedal where
after what like when you first go from a
single to a double pedal that the
[ __ ] brain power that you have to use
to move your left foot from the hi-hat
over to the slave pedal if you play a
good double pedal is like [ __ ]
ridiculous
but then after a while you just your
foot just knows to just sort of just
slide just to come over that you know
literally four inches but when you first
start off it's kind of the same things
like that alright I'm done
sorry Nia you literally just [ __ ]
glaze over like probably 80% of the
whatever it's soundproof it's something
that I do it's something she how good
they sound you can't hear it yeah
perfect that's [ __ ] perfect so how
are you how was your Christmas it was
lovely how was your Christmas it was
wonderful how was your new year you
doing so we had a nice Christmas yes we
did yeah
Oh cutie pie still doesn't get the whole
concept she was more into like opening
the presents yes she liked the opening
and the ripping of the wrapping paper
but after that she was like done yes she
was like no poison no present no present
so that was that I also love what does
she call the Christmas tree momma tree
momma tree like Christmas tree she's
like mama tree she's so manipulative
already I know she knows how to get you
you know because she knows how desperate
we are for her affection and her hugs
and kisses so she just uses that they
know that already don't they yeah
absolutely
so it's like you know she'll ask for
something that she knows you're not
supposed to have and I'm like no you
can't have that this and that and she'll
wear me down I'll be like all right you
can have a little mama please mama or
she sees I'm about to do it I've given
it and she rushes over and gives me a
kiss and a hug so it's like she just
knows so what's happening over here on
the old podcast their track suit I'm
loving this tracksuit tracksuit track
suit I got bill a couple of track suits
for Christmas because it's just like
what he likes to live in flash traveling
so you really I never do was of what
that's what's worse he's been telling me
to do forever and I never had always had
like track pants on and stuff at the
airport and like a zip up no cuz you
know what happens is because I I forget
my wallet or phone because most of them
don't have back pockets uh-huh that was
that time I went to the airport and I
missed my flight cuz I had my phone in
my front pocket and I wasn't even
thinking I didn't have my wallet I
didn't have my license and then I had to
fly [ __ ] private that cost me a
zillion dollars an afternoon gig yeah
yeah so I get super paranoid then I
don't like I don't like sweatpants when
I fly because [ __ ] just slides out of
your pockets and then your wallet goes
underneath the seat and somebody has to
find
think so but other than that they're
great to fly in so I just you know
something I put it in the hopefully yeah
see these don't have zip pockets yeah so
this is a very vulnerable this is like
the thing that the gypsies over there
are you not supposed to say gypsies by
the way I don't know let's look up let's
see if that's now offence I don't think
so I think you're something you're not
supposed to say I got gypped anymore
because I think that's offensive
to who gypsy gypsies but I feel like
you're not so call them I don't know
isn't our TV show called like gypsy
nation or something I don't know
I think gypsies is fine with like
pickpocketing and being scammers would
be like what happened to us when we were
over there is rude and you're not
supposed to say that you're not supposed
to say what the [ __ ] is happening
no all right hang on all right well then
fine I don't need to get involved in
this because I'm going to [ __ ]
Eastern Europe right exactly
lay off the old okay the harmful history
of gypsy mmm-hmm
this is on [ __ ] media so I don't think
that this is gonna be what is with all
these [ __ ] people asking for money
all right as a Romanian woman right more
often called by the racial slur gypsy I
didn't know that was a that's a racial
slur yeah I I feel like I learned that a
couple years ago but I'm but if I watch
TV networks original serie gypsy yet
some trepidation this show is a
psychological thriller for the most part
without many thrills me watch show that
I watched the show takes its inspiration
from Stevie Nicks song gypsy about a
free-spirited woman who loves and
disappears since to me that's what a
gypsy was that gypsy was just a nomadic
person like I didn't know anything [ __ ]
about pickpocket and all that [ __ ] the
the mythos said he said the gymnast is
of the gypsy is a stew of stereotype the
thief the fortune teller the free spirit
the seductress and the liar
Jeanne hits all of them rebranding them
as characteristics of a wealthy white
woman just trying to find herself that's
kind of true wait what's that salut
gypsy whoa what's that what's that song
that's from this no it's witchy woman oh
you're so racist against gypsy you're
throwing that word in Wow no I like that
so what is it now it's witchy woman yeah
you obviously know the lyrics more than
man yeah
well I think just for you know just
don't call anybody a gypsy all right
outside of us of a Stevie Nicks song the
Romanian people are an oppressed ethnic
minority whose disparate roots date back
to the 10th century India and are
currently in the mists of century long
human rights crisis see now it's
interesting to me because they have
their own country
who is that Romania right don't they is
that that their own country yes I feel
like everything that I'm saying is
[ __ ] offending somebody here probably
I don't know I mean I know Russia
controlled a lot of that party blame
them the Russians can we blame them feel
like you can blame the Russians and it's
okay long human rights crisis one part
is one one that is in part perpetuated
by the stereotypes of the gypsies yet
almost no one but the but the Roma
themselves are pushing back on the
series title slur the writing to the
network and producers are creating
partition to change the show's title
along with simple ignorance anti
Romanian sentiment is so normalized that
in 2017 a premiere streaming service can
release a show that takes an actual
racial slur and its title and no one
bats an eyelash well in defense of
Netflix over here
gypsies sort of a cool hey man like I'm
not stuck in the matrix kind of thing
like over here it doesn't mean that like
I never thought like
[ __ ] yet was definitely fortune teller
it was also and then that's what I don't
think of like just a free-spirited
hippie
I wouldn't like growing up you hear like
a gypsy person that's someone who is you
know yeah doing like scams and stuff so
you heard that I associated it with and
then go to Europe and people were like
be careful of the gypsies or ah be like
you know what I mean and then I didn't
know that gypsies were and half the
actual ethnicity right I just thought it
was like a hippie anybody gonna be a
[ __ ] hippie man you get a tambourine
and grow your [ __ ] hair and smoke a
little grass yeah all of a sudden the
drum drum culture right drum circle
hippie but no no no no no no no but I'm
saying I thought gypsy was like that
well I could I could become a hippie if
I got some hair transplants and started
smoking some weed man and just did you
know wearing Birkenstocks I could be
considered a hippie I didn't know that
it was an ethnicity right so we're
learning something here
wait would you ever get one of those
scalp ooh I wouldn't let you do it one
of those scalped what do they call it
scalp transplants like the the tattoo
scalp oh you know that's different a
scalp transplant off of murderer and
then I have even more of a temper scalp
transplant
yeah anyway someone know people follow
an Instagram does it for people like
it's a new thing that he's started to do
and he calls it like the scalp shop or
something and so I was watching a video
of the pronto it's not a new thing
that's that's been around for a while I
would have I know yeah it's a tattoo
yeah I knew a guy that did it it's
permanent then no it actually fades are
you supposed to keep your head out of
the light but what it looks like it ends
up looking like I have a full head of
hair but I just tried to shave I decided
to shave it like a five o'clock shadow
on your head yeah but then what this is
what's weird to me is like and now I
gotta shave my head every [ __ ] day
right because then it's gonna be weird
cuz then the stubble the real hair is
gonna be coming up and then the rest of
this [ __ ] I think you can go like a day
or two before it starts looking stupid
yeah I don't know I am NOT a I am NOT a
big believer in [ __ ] with nature okay
so play the hand that you were dealt and
you you play it to the best right so I
keep myself in shape I grew the beard I
just shaved it off and you know this is
a way we're talking about shaving your
beard off the other day and I was just
like why would you ever do that because
I miss my face oh Jesus yeah you may be
filming familiar with the word [ __ ] which
means to cheat someone right as a gypsy
would it's a slur as obviously offensive
as Jude down and yet people still say it
say what Jew down you never heard that
you grew up in Massachusetts for a while
I mean I live there toes like sex
oh I grew up in Atlanta what's yeah
people they got tails like they went to
a whole other level down there and yet
people still say in everyday say in
everyday combination imagine replacing
jiffy gypsy as the show title with
another ethnic slur the show would never
have been made and yet gypsy was made
riding on the back of the romantic
popularization of the world of fashion
beauty and social media yet that's how I
view it alright so I didn't know so I
guess I I will stop saying gypsy yeah
and stop saying I was saying and I will
say Romanian speaking of tails because
you mentioned tails earlier did you see
that video on Twitter did you see that
video on Twitter of the raccoon this is
in Florida a raccoon you know Mike one
of my least favorite animals like
attacking a lizard like one of those big
[ __ ] lizards and like like chasing it
through a parking lot oh my god we in
the heebie jeebies just thinking about
it chasing it through a parking lot and
just like sinking it's like teeth into
its neck and just holding it down and
then like dragging it out of frame and
then the person pans over to what looks
like a snake flapping around
just like what the [ __ ] is going on then
you realize it's the tail
it's the lizard's tail that if somehow
gotten like away from the lizard's body
and it's still flapping around on its
own it's a video every person nature I
gotta watch it I [ __ ] hate I hate
reptiles it's so I don't hate reptiles
ooh
can you imagine calling a show reptiles
yes no no no I want to see raccoon verse
lizard yeah Florida oh yeah Florida it's
[ __ ] crazy
raccoon kills iguana iguana oh man I
like iguanas piggy you're about to get
your heart broken oh no oh yes dude what
the [ __ ] does Gordon Ramsay have to do
with the goddamn lizard eat all I say
he's fixing these peoples restaurant
that's hilarious
through my favorite part about him going
to his restaurants is when Gordon Ramsay
starts gagging it's always something in
the [ __ ] freezer no it smells that
when they have meat from like yeah
2002 in there yeah oh my god he one time
like he I thought he was just acting and
then the cameraman almost puked I was
like oh wow that's real all right here
we go Oh No
Oh No where the [ __ ] did that goddamn
let me ask you this Chris who'd have
nobody has an iguana in Flitz a pet
somebody just let that thing go what you
just saw was how long I would last in
prison that [ __ ] lizard did not have
a goddamn chance yeah it's not natural
to [ __ ] Florida somebody got sick of
feeding at grasshoppers and it just let
it go and then it got eaten by a [ __ ]
you might not laser beam like what in
the [ __ ] is this thing you would survive
in prison based on your wicked looks no
because you like have so much anger
inside of you that you would be able to
channel it and you'd be able to like the
funny like killer guy it'll make you
laugh but oh he'll make you cry no all
right thing I've learned from anybody in
prison is just like that I have some of
the toughest [ __ ] guys ever met they
were like do not go in there acting like
you're the toughest [ __ ] guy because
you're not like why do you even think
about like how you would do in prison
like is there something that you need to
tell me no it's just you just watch
those think they need some [ __ ]
option yeah gonna happen I never think
about that and everything about how
would I do in prison well I don't have
in your privileged world oh here we go
wait but I want to say something about
the UM well try to save us oh wait wait
so that guy on the video was saying oh
should I break up the fight should I
stop it and I said no I understand why
people where people feel like they need
to get like involved in maitland nature
I was reading this article that's
because we already were involved what do
you mean
because whoever I promptly [ __ ]
bought that lizard to Florida was a
white person on some levels what I'm
guessing well I'm just saying like
sometimes you just have to
I left this comment on New York the New
York Magazine Instagram page because
they had a whole article about how seals
are snorting eels seals sea lions are
snorting eels as like this like they're
young and they snort them it's like for
fun or something like that and someone
left a comment like oh I hope whoever
took that picture like put the camera
down and like intervenes and like help
that poor sea lion and I was like
sometimes you just gotta let nature
nature
wait-wait-wait-wait-wait this snorting
deal they're snorting yells wait you
have to do the less sea lions are
snorting eels like like doing like a
line of coke yes and there's a picture
of a seal with like a sea lion with a
very satisfied look on its face with an
L up its nose that's just what they're
doing now I don't know why but someone
was like oh somebody should intervene
and pull it out and sure just let nature
do what its gonna judge them planking or
like throwing the water bottle and
having it land it's like their little
Instagram like it's a new thing that
they just apparently are just doing for
fun because they can do so it's like
just let them snort like you don't have
to get involved to like steal like what
what does I don't know I don't
understand that impulse to intervene
when nature is making white people are
control freaks it's one thing if you see
me I only attacking your cat or dog of
course but I mean if it's if it's a sea
lion and the eel or an iguana
and a fossil what you're saying leave it
you're saying that a dog in a cat is
more of an animal worth saving than a
lizard or an eel one of them that is
animal racism animal phobic speciesism
your wild of phobic you don't like wild
animals no I'm saying if they're in the
wild and they're doing their thing just
let let them do what they're gonna do
why do you need to get involved and like
how do you decide whose side to be on
just because the iguanas losing all of a
sudden you're anti the raccoon like you
go lighter skinned you pick the letter
skin animal okay on repairing
electronics all right so I'm not saying
gypsy anymore my apologies - yeah no man
that screwed but then that's offensive
prostitutes
I'm gonna say like no carpenters all
right on he screwed me on repairing
electronics hello bill you mentioned in
a previous podcast that you like getting
electronics repaired and even knew a guy
that did that it's amazing with a quick
youtube video people can repair their
own products well guess what Apple like
always is that one company that likes to
[ __ ] all over that they see shipments
with quality third parties party parts
from these repair shops because they
want you to pay the 800 plus you would
otherwise be saving Wow trusted repair
shops get third-party parts illegal but
Apple likes legally sorry but Apple
likes to have customers hold them from
these guys and make them pay obnoxious
fees to receive the packages when you
have the time take a look at this short
video you know we should ask the points
we go to for our our electronics repairs
like our computers and stuff we should
ask them about that you know what we
found a repairman who just fixed our
stove and it's [ __ ] amazing he did he
took the whole thing apart so now we had
we hadn't we have a 10 year old Viking
stove that is now 2018 it's basically a
restomod if you were into cars which is
if you had a 1965 whatever and on top it
looks like 1965 oh wait so it doesn't do
it doesn't do that anymore does it I
wish you wouldn't either I don't have
time to watch this but I'm definitely
gonna watch this it's called the name of
this video is Apple under fire for
allegation of controversial business
practices oh wait is this yours oh yeah
I was gonna give that to Bert Kreischer
I forgot that is a Florida State half
shirt that I bought 1981 or 82 never
worn a crop top I never wore vintage
Florida State crop top yeah caPSURE crop
top no they were called half shirts but
you're gonna give it to Burke right sir
yeah
Wow can you fit like an arm in here no I
didn't realize it's a small you know
idea I'd like to see you wear that I
think you were also you mentioned your
DVD or blu-ray player didn't have HDMI
for your new TV you can buy an RCA to
HDMI converter for a couple of bucks to
plug in an old video equipment or RGB to
HDMI depending on what you have RCA is
the red is the cable with red white and
yellow RGB is the cable with red green
and blue no [ __ ]
[Music]
watch it watch it
alright we've got time to read two more
here home sauna
Merry Christmas Billy big balls merry
Christmas to you and yours and I hope
you're having a lovely restful festive
break I just wanted to weigh in on your
home saunas Psalm sauna comments I
couldn't remember I couldn't recommend
getting one more I live in wet Wales and
built a sauna three years ago it's the
perfect way to level your body in mind
three times a week is perfect but I
generally do too the best way I found is
fifteen-minute in the sauna to a cold
shower out cold outdoor shower three
repeat steps one and two three times and
all the level of chill I have afterwards
can only otherwise be obtained by a
legal means it's awesome I'm telling you
this is gonna help us if I get something
like this looking forward to seeing you
in Manchester I [ __ ] love Manchester
okay
yeah they're like I wonder I went there
I was like these guys like the same kind
of [ __ ] lunatics I remember in Boston
same thing ball breaking drinking
[ __ ] I love it and I'm thinking
Liverpool's gonna be the same way and
all like all up to there I'm not doing
Newcastle I don't think but I just feel
like all up there is is that type of
[ __ ] where London is more like Manhattan
where it's all refined
thanks for bringing up my work week and
look after yourself I would love to
figure out a way to do this I just don't
have the room here
what's wrong with this theme though well
a sonnet you can go way hotter because
with steam it's it's it's so wet like I
mean you steam you can actually sit in a
sauna at like close to 200 degrees and
if you were in a sauna where was this
all all on a sauna a [ __ ] steam yeah
you literally beginning to the point
where the water on you was getting close
to starting to boil yeah he could burn
yourself I never understood this is and
this is also me speaking just trying to
remember repeating what people were
talking about saunas but I am sold on
them to the point there's one I know
that you know maybe we can go take a
sauna today if you wanted to and they
have like the Finnish one not like
Finnish I'm done like Finland and then
no they don't do that [ __ ] yeah although
recently just had a competition so many
[ __ ] Dido you can't say I didn't try
[Applause]
the old hot box I liked the hot box
alright I gotta wrap this up cuz I get a
phone call in a minute alright threesome
with my ex-girlfriend
dill dear Billy barren skull burr no
I've recently been going through some of
your cattle at podcasts and highlights
they become a huge fan I always have
your podcast playing at any opportunity
I get but without further ado here's my
dilemma
he's 16 in high school recently started
dating this girl at school
we've been going steady and part of my
graphing this has been doing it like
rabbits now these are like underage
people my allowed to read this stop this
is where I stop right okay alright I'm
gonna stop with underage threesome the
cops I'm not cool yeah why don't you
hype your Instagram page hey everybody
follow me on IG
[Laughter]
everybody knows my Instagram it's Nia's
alter-ego everybody they don't hockey is
that knee is alter-ego yes alter-ego
it's the same one Twitter as it is on
Instagram yeah there you go follow me
there you go as you build your brand as
I build my brand uh can we come to
England when you do that when we go to
what build your brand in England no can
we me and the baby come it's your
England land uh yeah sure you kind of
put me on the spot here yeah I know
okay evidently this trip is gonna cost
well I figure you do you're sure you
know I don't know you know I love London
yes I love London don't make me laugh
don't make me love heavy jungle a long
face no I will live me I'm sweating you
a roasting bacon boy like a sauna it's
like a sauna yeah all circle that's me
and B B's favorite movie I'm having a
calamari what you have what you have it
what are you having and we ran into them
that time we Roundtree yes round trade
yes you will
you will yeah well no look like a right
cut [ __ ] off
you're doing it I'll piss plane crashes
it's my favorite layer
EDD I love when he talks about I get
molested he touched me on the plane yeah
I was scared I didn't know what to do I
[ __ ] I've been touched I've been touched
he totally [ __ ] gets out of it
towstee a sexy beast if you haven't not
go see it I guess rent it or I don't
know how you procure old movies nowadays
but I'm sure it's on one of these
streaming services yes
services streaming services if it's not
on Netflix we need to have a
conversation with Ted surround us about
that
Ted Saran dose sexy beast on Netflix
that's right
and I was also opening when I have what
is it the good guys what's that Ryan
Gosling movie that I [ __ ] love it I
am sad that my [ __ ] loved it I still
haven't seen that movie Ryan Gosling and
Russell Russell Crowe Russell Crowe will
always be my favorite cuz he threw that
phone at the [ __ ] guy I wouldn't help
him with the phone and I always thought
how satisfying that would be when
someone is not helping you with
something and you throw the thing the
literally the thing they're not helping
you with you throw it at them sure
there's regret afterwards but in the
moment in the moment so good it feels so
good oh the release that's an angry sona
all right I got to go Happy New Year
everybody Thank You New Year thank you
once again my apologies to the people in
the Oh our last night I [ __ ] up had I
known that's all on me that's not on the
Comedy Store so send all your complaints
to me alright that's it go [ __ ]
yourselves and I'll check in on you
hopefully on Thursday I think I'll still
be traveling I'll be ahead of you then
I'll be ahead of the game see you in
2019 oh Jesus
[Music]
[Laughter]